(epic orchestral music)
- [Narrator] In London,
Ontario, there lives a man
whose basement is unlike
anything you've ever seen.
This is Robert Wardhaugh.
- Hi, my name is Robert Wardhaugh.
- [Narrator] Robert has
been playing the same
Dungeons and Dragons
campaign for over 30 years.
- 35 years to be exact.
- [Narrator] I'm sorry.
- That's okay.
Welcome, would you like
to play a Dwarven rogue.
You look like a rogue.
- [Narrator] Wait, let's
back up for a second.
Dungeons and Dragons is a
fantasy roleplaying game
where a group of people
come together and play out
adventures dictated by a dungeon master.
These adventures, also
known as campaigns, are set
in the Dungeons and Dragons world
and normally have an end point.
Or they just fizzle out due to
people's lack of commitment.
But Robert is in a league of his own
and here's why:
The dude has a serious collection.
- I think our collection of
miniatures is around 20,000
and then over the years
I discovered terrain.
Ultimately, I'm a collector
also and a lot of my enjoyment
comes from being able to get
new stuff and to put new stuff
on the table so the players
are constantly coming across new settings.
Because it's a game that
doesn't stick to one particular
campaign setting, I'm able to use any figs
that actually fit the world.
And so it is a long
process but over 35 years,
you could develop quite the collection.
- [Narrator] As Robert's collection grew,
so did the number of players.
Word began to spread about
the never-ending campaign.
- We have people coming from
all over the country to play,
often flying in.
- [Narrator] Wait, all over the country?
- That's right.
- [Player] Robert, can we play now?
- [Narrator] These are some of the people
who play in Robert's game.
Where are you guys from?
- I flew in from Saskatoon, Saskatchewan.
- I drove in from Toronto.
- Brussels, Ontario.
- Komoka, Ontario.
- Calgary, Alberta.
- [Narrator] Hold on, what
happens if people can't fly in
or drive to Robert's house to play?
- Hey everyone.
- [Narrator] Problem solved.
- On top of the ridge,
looking down upon this and.
The game has always been determined,
really through a friendship.
It's really been a way that
I keep my friends together.
I knew early on that if I
was able to create a game
that was good enough, and
that means it had to be better
than video games, it had to
be better than any other game
that they could find, that
they would keep coming,
no matter where I was and so
that takes again, imagination
and it takes change and
it takes having a system
that is constantly
dynamic, that is changing,
that is growing and that is
constantly getting better.
(dramatic orchestral music)